and the Oscar goes
to Martin Square could could you double
check the
envelope thank you so I mean I I'm
overwhelmed um um with this honor with
the academy and also the honor of um
being presented by my old old friends we
go back 37 years I'm so moved and so
moved I so many people over the years
have been wishing this for me strangers
you know I go I walking in the street
people say something to me I go in a
doctor's office I go whatever elevators
people saying I wish you should win me I
should win I go for an x-ray you should
win one and U I'm saying thank you and
then the like friends friends of mine
over the years and friends who are here
tonight are wishing this for me and my
family I thank you this is for you and
and I want to thank my daughter Cathy
who here tonight who worked on the film
and Dominica my wife Ellen and our
little Franchesca who's seven years old
who's watching right now Franchesca stay
up for another 10 minutes but then jump
up and down and make a lot of noise at
the hotel okay I'll see you in the
morning thank you